[Music]
da da Sawa good morning everyone
now the press conference begins we will
use simultaneous interpretation and
please put on your earphone now I would
like to give the floor to dreamy atleast
president tusk president Juncker friends
from the press it gives me great
pleasure to meet the press with two
presents this morning dear president and
I have a small group meeting when we had
in-depth and candid and friendly
exchange of views on major issues of
mutual interest and after that we had
the twenties China EU summit when the
two present and I as the co-chairs of
the summit had exchange of views well
this is a commemorative event as we mark
the 20th anniversary of such a summit in
both the small and large group meetings
we agreed that given the complicated and
fluid international landscape it is
important for China and EU to uphold
multilateralism and advance the building
of a multipolar world and greater
democracy in international relations
this will help contribute to global
peace
we also agreed to safeguard free trade
and to strengthen the momentum of global
recovery to prevent any stagnation of
global economy China and EU are two
forces for stability and two major
economies we take our strategic
communication cooperation as an
important agenda and the two sides
sending out a positive signal for multi
lies a multilateralism is a positive
contribution to the world and we want to
prove through our actions for free trade
that our bilateral cooperation is
beneficial to marshal naturalism and to
free trade indeed in the process of
globalization
they have emerged they saw that kind of
problems but the trend of globalization
is moving forward and of course in light
of new problems and issues we need to
improve the governance system including
the WTO while upholding the WTO
principles and the rules-based order and
free trade we feel it is necessary to
improve and reform the WTO and China and
you stand ready to have communication
and to set up a communication mechanism
of course WTO and other multilateral
institutions
I'll preach on consensus of multiple
parties China EU cooperation will not
replace multilateral cooperation
mechanisms and we will respectively
communicate and consult with other
parties concerned in the world by
upholding the multilateral trading
system we want to achieve more open
trade and more transparent and inclusive
trade for non discriminative practices
and to improve the sanctity and
authority of the WTO and in our meetings
we reaffirmed our firm support for
European integration we want to see
united and prosperous EU and we want to
have all the emotional cooperation with
EU and EU countries and sub regional
mechanisms of EU and all such
cooperation or contribute to prosperity
of Europe we want to see greater
development of Europe and more progress
in European integration
we also discussed China's cooperation
with some European countries our
cooperation follows international rules
and EU laws and regulations and our
cooperation is conducted as for the
purpose of contributing a positive
energy to EU and such cooperation will
also help with China's efforts to uphold
multilateralism
the two presents and I agreed to
in-house china EU trade and economic
cooperation and chart the course for the
future growth we believe that we need to
advance the BI tea negotiations now that
we have exchanged the office it marked a
new stage of our negotiations we share
the objective of concluding the
agreement at an early date we also
agreed to conclude the geographical
indicators agreement by October this
year and we believe that it is a piece
of good news in particular for our trade
in agricultural goods and China wants to
seek a more balanced trade relations
with EU China's Dorf opening up will
only open wider to the outside world
Chinese government recently has taken
the host of measures including reducing
tariffs and expanding market access I
just paid a visit to Germany and
witnessed the signing of an agreement
between a big German company and a
Chinese one it will invest 10 billion
euro for sole ownership in China and we
also discussed the foreign equity cap by
European companies investment in China
the foreign company concerned will raise
its share to 75% there are many such
examples I won't go into details here I
want to make the point said China will
significantly raise its market access
and we will reduce the tariff rates for
goods that are needed for Chinese
companies and consumers in particular
recently we abolish tariffs for certain
drugs and additional taxation this will
benefit Chinese consumers but it takes a
process for institutional adjustments
but China's determination for greater
openness is firm as for the agricultural
Goods and effective drugs needed by
Chinese people be it in the chemical
sector automobile sector or sectors
closely related to people's well-being
we will see greater openness for the
purpose of ensuring a better life for
the Chinese people this way we will
provide more choices for the consumers
we will make the markets more open and
transparent and provide a level playing
field and for foreign companies European
ones included we will continue to
provide a good business environment for
them let me repeat here that as long as
you register in China you will be
treated the same as Chinese companies
and we forbid any forced transfer of
intellectual property
and we will deal with IP violations with
all seriousness and for those who
violate intellectual property there will
we will punish them to the full extent
of the law so that they cannot afford to
commit such violations or the ministers
present here and I will make the promise
here if any foreign company feels that
they fight their IPR is seriously
violated please let us know and we will
tell with such cases immediately while
protecting the IP our foreign companies
we actually protecting the innovation of
Chinese companies because Chinese
companies also need to protect their IPR
for their future development the left
facts speak for themselves
technics investment for example we say
openness in the investment sector we
need to take facts very seriously and we
need to study the cases very seriously
to see how we can further open the
market like I said China an EU exchanged
offers of investment agreement today and
on intellectual property and other
matters please feel free to let us know
if you feel that you are treated
unfairly in China now in a word there is
a wide range of areas where China and
you have been in cooperating with each
other we will step up people-to-people
and cultural exchanges and cooperation
on connectivity and on cutting over
capacity we covered a lot of ground
during our discussions we talked about
human rights we believe that on the
basis of mutual respect and equality we
will enhance cooperation on human rights
we talked about cyber security and we
agreed that China and EU will strengthen
communication on this matter
try the EU will have a better
understanding on China's laws and
regulations in China will update its
knowledge about EU latest legislation on
cyber security so that in the age of
digital economy we will have better
communication to protect personal
information protect IPR and protect
trade secrets
we also discussed international issues
we about mafia tourism and we uphold
peace for solutions to disputes and
differences we both are opposed to
terrorism and we will take common
response to regional conflicts and we
believe in negotiations and cooperation
to properly settle regional issues in a
word a lot of common ground has been
reached and let me say here as I shared
with my colleagues in the EU
see latest developments of China and
Central and Eastern in Central and
Eastern European countries cooperation
we want to seek mutual benefit thank you
Thank You mr. premier now I will give
the floor to mr. president
tsk
Thank You mr. premier good morning dear
colleagues let me first of all thank you
Premier Li for your warm welcome here in
Beijing we just finished a fruitful
meeting in which we agreed to develop
the EU China strategic partnership
further we discussed foreign and
security cooperation and the situation
in our respective neighborhoods we
reiterated our support for the peaceful
resolution of the North Korean nuclear
issue so diplomatic means and for
complete denuclearization of the Korean
Peninsula
we also United in our commitment to the
continued full and effective
implementation of the Iran nuclear deal
and today we will also discuss into
political situations in our
neighbourhood including the conflict in
Ukraine and I want just to repeat that
our position is that the only way the
sustainable solution to the conflict in
Ukraine is through the full
implementation of the Minsk agreement on
human rights it is not always easy to
find agreement as differences persist
but we agreed to enhance exchanges in
follow-up to the recent Human Rights
dialogue now let me repeat what I told
Prime Minister Lee at our meeting a bit
earlier today on the same day as Europe
meets China in Beijing American
President Trump and Russian President
Putin will talk in Helsinki
we are all aware of the fact that the
architecture of the world is changing
before our very eyes and it is our
common responsibility to make it a
change for the better let us remember
here in Beijing and over there in
Helsinki that the world we were building
for decades sometimes through disputes
has brought about peace for Europe the
development of China and the end of the
Cold War between the East and the West
it is a common duty of Europe and China
America and Russia not to destroy this
order but to improve it
not to start trade wars which turned
into hot conflict so often in our
history but to bravely and responsibly
reform the rules-based international
order this is why I am calling on our
Chinese host but also on the president's
Trump and Putin to jointly start this
process from a reform of the WTO there's
still time to prevent conflict and chaos
today we are facing a dilemma whether to
play a tough game such as tariff Wars
and conflict in places like Ukraine and
Syria or to look for common solutions
based on fair rules this is why
responsibility predictability spirit of
cooperation and respect for our common
rules and commitments are so important
these days
the EU is committed to working towards
the modernization of the WTO and calls
from all partners to contribute
positively to this goal we propose a
comprehensive approach to improving
together with like-minded partners the
functioning of the WTO in crucial areas
we need new rules in the field of
industrial subsidies intellectual
property and forced technology transfers
reduction of trade costs as well as a
new approach to development and more
effective dispute settlement the aim of
this reform should be to strengthen the
WTO as an institution and to ensure a
level playing field thank you
she's here to see something wrong how to
seize upon now I give the floor to
present tronca Prime Minister colleagues
ladies and gentlemen I'm delighted to be
back in Beijing for this 20th China you
submit I first visited China back in
1996 as prime minister of Luxembourg and
it's always a pleasure to come back and
to see China grow and transform into the
into a truly global country I've always
been a strong believer in the potential
of the EU China partnership and in
today's world the partnership is more
important than ever before our
cooperation simply makes sense together
we account for around a third of the
global economy Europe is China's largest
trading partner and China is your second
largest trading partner the trade in
goods between us is worth over 1.5
billion euros every single
last year Europe exported 198 billion
euros worth of goods and 38 billion euro
in services to China discouraged jobs
and growth both sides and shows the
potential of our trading partnership but
you also know that we can do much more
European foreign direct investment into
China have hit a low in 2017 at one six
million euros million years this
compares to over 30 billion euros
invested by China in Europe last year
this gap reflects the concerns amongst
our investors on the regulatory and
administrative burden that foreign
companies sometimes have to face in
China build wants to do more and to
invest more in China on the basis of a
level playing field and the degree tools
but in open investment environment works
when it's two-way in that spirit I
welcome the first exchange of offers
that we have made on the comprehensive
agreement on investment this is an
important step but only the first one
what we need is an agreement that
fulfills our common ambition and gives
investors on both sides predicted and
long-term access to our respective
market Aveda more in the personal honor
of collaging was revealed that one touch
the legs are look luminous to VND Dorne
the example that the Prime Minister is
just given referring to investment large
investment by German company this is a
without any restrictions this is a very
important development it shows that if
China wishes to open up it can do so it
knows how to open up that is why I very
much welcome the fact both sides
China and us have agreed to put in place
a working group on reforming the World
Trade Organization it's not just a
matter of setting up a working group but
we have to show that actions are more
important than words
Thank You president Wong Kar now the
floor is open for questions the first
question comes from Financial Times
she said uterine it's only it's awesome
ha good morning mr. tusk mr. honker I am
from the Financial Times but I'm asking
questions on behalf of all of the
reporters in this room was her answer
bothered answer what I also love Iowa
cheetah chicken Jason go auntie firstly
for mr. Lee my cell showing you on the
trade war has dominated all of our
coverage for these last days do you
think that China can be successful in
creating a common international
coalition against the US actions and can
China successfully reform multilateral
institutions without the u.s.
cooperation my I'll ask all three at
once
for mr. Juncker the EU has in the past
expressed serious concerns over China's
industrial policies have those concerns
been satisfied or are you willing to put
them inside in the face of both sides
distress over the u.s. action and
finally for mr. tusk in the past month
we've witnessed numerous protests in
Europe by wiegert's who are concerned
about the arbitrary detention of
hundreds of thousands of their fellow
leaders in China is this a concern that
the EU has brought up as it engages in
with China in its one belt one road
program stated idea Madame journalist I
respect you raising questions to the
three of us on trade frictions between
China and the United States it is that
issue between China and the US China
does not want a trade war with the
United States because we believe no one
emerges as a winner from a trade war any
practice in violation of WTO rules
serves nobody's interest we are after
mutual benefit and wing wing wing wing
for both sides in addressing trade
frictions ultimately it's up to China
and the United States to work things out
as for China developing relations with
the EU and other parties I think we're
working together to uphold
multilateralism and free trade in my
small group discussion with the two
presidents I already made it clear that
our summit is not targeted at any third
party nor will it be affected by any
third party we are living in a
multi-holder world that calls for
multilateralism our world also needs
mutual understanding mutual respect and
win-win and all wing outcomes when it
comes to global trading rules China and
you have been talking to each other but
we must discuss this issue together with
other parties too as it affects all
members of the international community
but that does not stand in the way of us
having communication with the EU side
the same applies to global hotspot
issues we address these issues at the UN
platform we have also maintained
communication at the UN Security Council
but we
I've been having maybe bilateral or mini
lateral communication within the
Security Council but whatever format
such communication may takes it should
can contribute to the building of
multilateral consensus and it should not
add difficulty to the sentiment of by
bilateral issues or disputes bilateral
issues should be resolved at the
bilateral level and global issues
regional issues should also be addressed
through a building of global consensus
thank you yes deployment you're
mentioning it was at the center of our
discussions today as we were discussing
great I had a phone call with the
Chinese Prime Minister two weeks ago I
made the point we had the meeting
between six eyes and we made the point
we had a delegation meeting vice
president Catalan and Trade Commission
and also made the point if we have
listened carefully to the Prime Minister
you will have noted that we are making
progress I would like to underline that
we that we have discussed the problem of
human rights in a much broader contact
and only one belt one road and because I
have expressed our concerns regarding
the human rights situation in China and
I also raised specific individual cases
this is something I have consistently
done before during our
all our meetings I have done today and I
will continue think in the future as
long as necessary CJ Shari Givenchy
thank you next question from Co news
agency a question for Premier League
your opening remarks you said that the
two sides exchanged offers on the bi t
investment agreement showing negotiation
entering a new stage the business
communities in both size follow the ago
she ation with keen interest and hope
for early conclusion what are the
sticking points in a negotiation and
when to China hopeful of a negotiation
to be concluded and the agreement
reached I have the same respect for the
female journalist from China well
talking about the BI T negotiation
between the two sides
indeed we agreed to exchange offers
during the summit that shows that our
negotiations which have been going on
for four years have entered a new stage
involving substantive discussions and I
believe it will give a strong boost to
the negotiation process as we face
rising unilateralism and protectionism
it is important that we talk about how
we will uphold free trade and modulate
multilateralism we will also take
concrete actions and this exchange of
offers is a specific action we believe
both will help uphold the global order
it will also help foster a good
atmosphere for our bilateral
negotiations it may open up new
prospects for us in a
seeing our differences in the process we
hope that's the two working teams will
redouble their efforts and we also hope
that we will be able to announce at an
early date the launch of a joint
feasibility study of China EU FTA and we
believe that will communicate a positive
expectation to the international
community China and the EU should and
can send out a positive message the
world that our economies will keep
growing and our cooperation will also
gather momentum what I wish to add is
that principles and specific progress
has been reached at xx China EU summit
and we have agreed to issue a joint
statement this joint statement I believe
reflects the progress we have made in
the past three years and the fact that
we have been able to find solutions to
the various possible differences between
the two sides it also includes our joint
response and position on tackling
climate change and our cooperation on
clean environmental goods this
represents a tremendous market it also
means that we are doing our a bit to
fulfill our do share of responsibility
and these will also boost our bi T
negotiations thank you for material
without their services it
you